[Musique]
nous voici au coeur du projet pour une
école heureuse chaque matin les enfants
de la maternelle choisissent une
activité dans leur plan de travail ils
doivent la réaliser avant la récré qui
joue à dire un travail sur le bon air
bravache et après qu'eut lieu de faire
tu tues le ranger a break vient de ma
photo dr c'est
tout un drame ali près du pont loby
prévoir actuellement elle vit
la fois ci c'est tout à fait la halle
riquiqui la france se mérite
alors chaque travail et fait plusieurs
fois dans le plan de travail on voit
qu'il ya plusieurs petites cases et nous
on s'arrange toujours pour aller
vérifier
qu'un travail est fait jusqu'au bout la
photo peut aider parce qu'on peut voir
si la photo correspond pas du tout au
travail qu'à demander ou s'il n'a pas
été fait complètement ou pas jusqu'au
bout donc ça c'est une première chose on
nous on va regarder les photos de ce
qu'ils ont pu on peut valider ou pas et
puis en classe on
on va aussi se promener et voir
s'arrêter vers les élèves et on coche on
a aussi des tableaux de travail aux
autres tableaux où nous on va accrocher
ce que l'on a vu être vraiment réaliser
et puis par moments on a besoin d'aller
re vérifier
alors on va garder britannique moment ce
que tu as fait comme travail utah nous
[Musique]
montre moi oui d'accord c'est bon tu as
fait ta photo tu peux aller tablier
alors déjà on fonctionne un peu comme ça
dans nos classes auparavant on avait
déjà fait des tests chacune de notre
côté dans des écoles différentes et ça
nous plaisait vraiment de travailler
avec l'atelier autonome et avec des
enfants qui soit plus libre de choisir
ce qu'ils avaient envie de faire et de
pouvoir respecter le rythme de chaque
enfant et on se rend compte qu'il ya
effectivement des enfants qui vont très
vite de cette façon là qu'ils apprennent
beaucoup plus vite que dans ce que nous
ont pratiqué avant et qui ont déjà accès
à des compétences qui relèvent du sepem
et du coup on les prépare et avec une
approche qui est beaucoup plus dans la
manipulation et puis inversement on a
des enfants qui ont besoin de plus de
temps que ce qui est proposé la moyenne
est dans ce système là les enfants ont
aussi la possibilité de prendre plus de
temps est ce que tu peux me montrer la
lettre qui fait
on regarde comment elle fait
[Musique]
celui qui fait pendant ce temps en
autonomie la porte qui sépare les deux
classes de l'école est ouverte les
enfants sont tous ensemble qu'ils soient
chez les petits moyens ou grands
alors je trouve que l'ambiance de classe
et facilité que chaque enfant se
trouvent trouve davantage sa place quand
on mélange tous les niveaux et rien que
par l'observation et l'imitation les
petits apprennent beaucoup des plus
grands mais aussi à linverse les grands
prennent confiance en eux on l'aimé où
on les encourage à prendre soin des
petits et c'est une attitude de savoir
être qui est aussi très importante et
très valorisé à l'école brique après
brique mari marc ysaye camboulit et
stéphanie chaudron ont construit leur
projet ce n'est pas une méthode unique
mais un ensemble d'outils qui leur
convient
[Musique]
la première année on a démarré on a
passé trois semaines l'été à tout mettre
en place dans la classe tous les
ateliers atelier par plateau on a rentré
les items en prenant la photo de chaque
atelier donc ça ça c'est un gros travail
de démarrage de mise en place mais une
fois que ça c'est fait finalement il n'y
a pas plus de travail que dans n'importe
quelle école on suit les enfants ont
fait qu'ali de réussite comme partout et
on suit là où ils en sont et remplissant
leur évaluation comme ailleurs
mais moi je trouve que
dans le fonctionnement quotidien ça se
fait très facilement et je dirais même
peut-être même plus facilement un
fonctionnement qui déconstruit tout de
même la posture de l'enseignant c'est ce
que les institutrices nous expliquerons
delà